Where are the Avengers?
One last fight.
Doctor Doom
Victor
Von Doom is the greatest single character
in the entire MCU, bar None.
Now you can keep anyone else.
You've made Doctor Doom against anyone
because
Victor softens and you will now suffer,
you know?
That's
That's why it's a no brainer.
He's the first character
to ever have a substantial backstory
that we could understand,
and that gives context both in the old
traditional Cold War minus state
kind of idea and also as someone
who really got disfigured,
but his family taken from him
and then takes all that, takes
his skill has the wounds
and has to wear the mask and continues on
to do what he did.
The Fantastic Four suck, right?
They suck full stop.
They then sort of like Marvel's
first attempt to make it grow
and they suck, right?
That's why the X-Men Rule and Fantastic
four suck.
However, the fantastic Four birth,
the Skrulls and they birthed Doctor Doom.
So while they suck,
they also gave rise to the greatest
two villain group and single villain ever.
Give me.
Give me
that success from that lame
ass group of, like,
Flame on, man.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Marvel dropped another secret invasion
clip, all about the Fantastic Four and Doctor
Doom.
They're also getting ready
to announce the full cast
in the new Fantastic
Four movie pretty soon.
So we'll break it all down.
really love hearing the Marvel actors
being such huge fans
of those characters and so. Well, right.
Like you can definitely tell Ben
Mendelsohn knows his shit.
Give me.
If you're new to the channel,
I'm doing videos
for all the Secret Invasion episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
Plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know where you want
all the Fantastic Four characters in films
like Doctor Doom to cross over
in the upcoming Marvel movies.
the really cool thing about this
new secret invasion video is one
How much of a doctor doom stand
Ben Mendelsohn is in real life.
He's a genuine comic book fan.
You can tell he gets that the Fantastic
Four characters and the X-Men two.
the reasons why he's talking
so much about them is both because Marvel
is getting ready to debut new versions
of all those characters,
like we have the new Fantastic
Four movie coming.
Doctor Doom will also appear
in a different upcoming Marvel movie.
They've already been
a bunch of Easter eggs
for all those characters
in like John Krasinski's
version of Reed Richards Inside Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
and there's the new X-Men solo movie
that they'll release later on.
not to forget.
They're also doing the X-Men,
the animated series, X-Men 97, Season one.
it's kind of like
the continuation of X-Men,
the animated series that's supposed to
come at the beginning of next year, too.
And I will do videos
for when it does arrive.
but on
top of all this, Ben Mendelsohn
just grew up during an era
when all those characters Fantastic
Four X-Men,
were the most popular characters in Marvel
Comics next to people like Spider-Man,
The X-Men basically ruled the eighties
and the nineties
just from a sales perspective.
That's why it was such a big deal
When Marvel Phase one happened
in the first few movies,
two Avengers went so well
because even though Robert Downey
Jr was fantastic as Iron Man at the time,
Iron Man was viewed
as a B tier character in the comics.
so was Captain America, Thor, Hawkeye
Black Widow.
Kevin Feige, he has talked about this
a lot like it was a huge deal
because they were like,
How can we make this huge
franchise of movies
with a bunch of characters
that nobody cares about right now
in the comics cut to a few years later?
They did pretty well.
I think.
But. From a sheer
pop culture sales perspective, Spider-Man
is probably one of the most,
if not the most popular character
of all time from the comics.
the next closest ones
would be like Batman and Superman
Everybody else, for the most part, is
like way, way lower on the sales charts.
that's why
when Marvel went bankrupt in the nineties
and had to sell rights to its characters,
the Spider-Man rights
and the X-Men rights, Fantastic
Four were snatched up by Sony and Fox
right away, and they didn't really care
about the Marvel Phase one characters
like Iron Man, Captain America,
because at the time no one thought
that they make for good movies.
like nobody cares about them.
If we make a movie about them, it's
not going to make any money.
How wrong they were.
one of the other major
Fantastic Four Easter eggs during secret
invasion is the Super Skrull.
Planet Earth.
I am the super strong
emissary of the Imperial Strong
Expeditionary Forces.
I have been appointed by Emperor.
I'm Mark to be your new leader.
So the whole concept of the Super Skrull
is in the comics.
It was one character
there was created by the school emperor
at that time to fight the Fantastic
Four characters
back in the original comics
he was given the powers
of all the Fantastic Four characters.
And they had an Easter egg for that
during Fantastic
Four Rise of the Silver Surfer,
where you see Johnny Storms with the other
characters use multiple powers
from all the different characters
at the same time.
what it seems like they're doing
in the Secret Invasion series, though?
Is it?
They're grafting powers
from a bunch of different Marvel
based characters
that they've already done in the movies,
like Easter
Eggs, four previous Marvel movies,
and it'll be a bunch of super Skrulls
the other major reason
why they're talking so much about
Fantastic Four during the secret invasion
clip is because the Skrulls are primarily
fantastic Four characters.
They debuted in Fantastic Four.
Number two back in the sixties.
the reason
why you didn't see a ton of Fantastic
four references are characters
in the first Captain Marvel movie
when they introduce Skrulls to the MCU.
Was because at the time Marvel hadn't
got the rights back to its characters.
The box Disney deal hadn't gone down yet,
so they couldn't use
any of those Fantastic Four or X-Men
at the time now that's different.
We're getting Deadpool three.
There's going to be a bunch of those Fox
versions of the X-Men and Fantastic
Four characters coming back.
It's going to be sort of
like the Spider-Man
No Way Home for the Fox Marvel characters,
really hoping.
Chris Evans also comes back in cameos.
This is Johnny Storm.
He did say that he would be willing to do
that.
He'd be way quicker to come back as Johnny
Storm than he would be as his captain.
America.
generally, the Fox Disney deal,
having gone down a couple of years ago,
is why you're seeing so many Fantastic
Four, Doctor
Doom Easter eggs, even X-Men Easter eggs
in the current Marvel movies and TV shows
like Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
probably the best example of that,
like literally
seeing a version of Reed Richards
there's been some X-Men Easter Eggs,
but the first, like real big X-Men thing
that's going to be happening
will be in Deadpool three.
during the Secret Invasion episodes,
though, Reed Richards, Ben Grimm's
who storm Johnny Storm, even Doctor Doom
not supposed to show up
during those episodes, but a lot of what
Nick Fury and the good Skrulls are doing
with the saber Space station will connect
with the Fantastic Four characters.
primarily
because they're a space based team
that just happens to live on planet Earth.
Like most of the biggest Fantastic
Four villains come from space somewhere.
Galactus, for example, is supposed to be
one of the metaphorically and literally
biggest characters in the new Fantastic
Four movie.
There are even reports
that Antonio Banderas
will be playing the characters
he had to imagine,
like the Puss in Boots
sounding version of Galactus.
He does have a really good
speaking voice, though.
He'll make you feel really good
about yourself as he destroys your planet.
in the present day,
the MCU, though,
there are some rumors that they're
actually going to do the Fantastic
Four movie plot
just a little bit differently.
big twist is that it might wind up
being a period piece
set in the 1960s
in a time travel adventure
where they're kicked back into time
through an experiment that goes wrong
and they have to find their way back
to the present
by the events of Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty.
But ultimately.
The new Fantastic
Four characters will be interacting
with the present day Avengers.
Marvel just canceled their Comic-Con plans
that there's no big Marvel panel
that's going to be happening.
They were going to announce
the cast of the Fantastic Four they're
and even though
there were a bunch of actors
that were announced a while ago,
reportedly
some of those actors have passed
because of the delays
with all those strikes,
pretty much everything has been delayed
indefinitely through the summer.
reportedly right now,
the only actor that's locked in is Daveed
Diggs as the thing.
So if you weren't happy
with some of the casting choices
that were announced a little while ago,
it sounds like those actors
won't wind up playing the characters.
So you should be safe,
Let me know in the comments
who you want to play all those characters.
Even though most people believe that
it will not wind up being John Krasinski,
Coming back is another alternate reality
version of Reed Richards
In the other big change
they're making is that Doctor Doom
isn't supposed to be in the new Fantastic
Four movie.
He's not going to be a villain
in the first movie.
He might be a reference in some way,
but he's not supposed to be
a big character during that.
He'll appear in some other Marvel movie,
I think part of the reason for
that is they're leaning
into the whole technology versus magic.
Like he's meant to be a man of both magic
and science.
so he's a character that works in Iron
Man technology based stories,
but he also works in Doctor Strange, magic
based stories to see, you could put him
in pretty much any Marvel story
that you would want to tell. end.
I think part of the idea
with this new version of the Fantastic
Four characters is that Marvel wants to do
something that hasn't been done before,
So they don't want the characters
to be exactly
like they were during the Fox Fantastic
Four movies.
in they started to get into that during
Black Panther, which kind of forever.
But reportedly
they took out a lot of the doctor doom
Easter eggs that they had planned on early
when they
started to do the name for character.
my fall Secret Invasion Episode
three Video we'll post next week after it
releases.
There's a bunch of big stuff happening to
a new Ahsoka trailer supposed to release.
I'll do a video for that.
You can click here for my Secret Invasion
Episode 3 video
and click here for that
brand new Ahsoka trailer.
Update the link as soon as I post that.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!